la vacunación contra la kobe 19 es un
reto mundial pero en el líbano además de
combatir al coronavirus hay que luchar
contra la corrupción política casos como
el escándalo del presidente michel aún y
el de un grupo de parlamentarios
vacunados sin respetar el turno pone de
manifiesto la importancia de este equipo
de los observadores de la federación de
la cruz roja es la primera misión que
hacemos para monitorear la campaña de
vacunación en el mundo nuestro trabajo
es que se cumplan los estándares
internacionales y se respeten los
requisitos del banco mundial
fermina antes del tema para vigilar que
no hayan fallos en el registro de
vacunación y se suministren
correctamente las vacunas es necesario
aumentar el número de observadores
independientes para que se cumpla la
meta de vacunar al 80% de la población a
final de año
angela el general de nauta vi la ciudad
del este está condenada lo apoyamos a
las autoridades de salud porque el
líbano está bajo una gran presión por la
crisis económica sanitaria y por la
explosión del puerto nuestra
colaboración ayudará a superarla
mientras el equipo de sara intenta
garantizar la transparencia en la
distribución los responsables médicos
están preocupados por la limitada
cantidad de vacunas que han llegado a
líbano
redd kross y agradecemos el trabajo de
los observadores de la cruz roja pero lo
que necesitamos en los centros son más
vacunas para inocular a los grupos
prioritarios el lema no registró un
nuevo pico de contagios con más de 7000
casos diarios a mediados de enero lo que
llevó a las autoridades a implementar
estrictas medidas de confinamiento que
se mantienen a día de hoy estas
restricciones sólo han hecho que
empeorar la crisis económica pero con la
nueva campaña de vacunación y la misión
de los observadores se ve una pequeña
luz al final del túnel